we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a guy who really
doesn't like that I talk and comment
when I do coverage of rallies last night
we covered uh we we tried to cover the
Bernie rally and we covered the Trump
rally and this guy doesn't like that I
sometimes say things and he makes an
interesting point about my
qualifications to have an opinion
you're laughing because you're part of
the problem
and you've never been overseas all
you've done is sit on your skinny little
ass
and done nothing with your life I I've
been overseas plenty of places I've been
dozens of countries I don't know what
they're talking about except talking to
a microphone you've never squeezed a
trigger on anybody
oh that's true no if he means I haven't
been overseas with the military killing
people
that
guilty is charged I have never shot
anyone the caller is correct about that
that being said I don't know why I need
to have shot people
or shot at people
in order to have opinions about things
that's strange I don't know where else
this individual applies that
uh Mr dentist
I know you want to do my root canal but
have you ever squeezed the trigger at
people overseas you haven't oh well that
by no means okay very very dangerous and
sick people we have a great bonus show
for you today
Twitter has started advertising its page
verification plan for eight dollars a
month oh the bonus show where you want
to make money
and themselves is bad we will indeed
talk about it on the bonus show New York
City employers are now requiring salary
ranges to be posted I like this I like
this even as an employer and I'm going
to tell you why and then lastly the U.S
defense intelligence report on UFOs will
soon be made public I will tell you what
some people are expecting what I am
expecting and we will delve into it a
little bit more so much going on in the
next 24 hours the election is tomorrow I
will be live tomorrow night starting
between 7 and 8 Eastern on YouTube
twitch and Facebook with election
results we're going to go for a while I
don't know how long I hope you will join
me tonight we will be live with multiple
rallies starting at 7 30 PM Eastern also
on YouTube twitch and Facebook it is all
happening on those platforms so it's all
free I'm selling you nothing
follow us on Twitch for free
subscribe to the YouTube channel for
free like the Facebook page for free so
then you can get if you want you can get
notifications when all of these live
streams happen
a very very big 24 to 36 hours in
American politics that I will I believe
will be of massive consequence going
forward see everybody then and of course
to get today's bonus show simply sign up
at joinpakman.com